all right
Rachel hi Rachel uh where'd you grow up
where you from originally I was born in
wasika
Minnesota it's a small town that even
people from Minnesota have never heard
of it's really really small and tell me
about your childhood growing up my
childhood growing up um divorced parents
um I've us lived with my mother um
pretty abnormal noral childhood I would
say um my mom was
uh a partyer she liked sex drugs and
rock and roll and um I was never allowed
to call her mom just in case you know
there was a man around and uh she didn't
want me to be the daughter so um it was
It was kind of crazy um a lot of drugs a
lot
of parties um was not the lifestyle that
I would have chosen so I I kind of
gravitated towards animals at a very
young age and they became my friends
because I couldn't rely on or count on
people so um I became an animal lover at
a very young age I had a pet guinea pig
that was my best friend and that's who I
would talk to and I felt sad or did you
have friends scared I really didn't have
human friends no
no
and you went through High School you
graduated no I never went to high school
I um my last grade I completed was
8ighth grade I started modeling um in
fashion at the age of 16 so I went to um
Tokyo Japan and uh by myself I had an
agency of course but um I it was the
start of my modeling career and I did
that for over 10 years back and forth um
throughout Asia did that bring you to
Los Angeles as well I moved to Los
Angeles in 2000 so I did that for over
10 years in fashion and um moved to Los
Angeles and discovered that um there's
the world of Playboy so um I did my
first nude photo shoot in 2000 got hired
to um do several different things for
Playboy over the years um Playboy Radio
Playboy TV um I was a Cinemax star I've
probably done every Cinemax show that
they've ever invented they still play
them to this day um a lot of sof all
softcore
um no actual sex on film but um I was
the softcore Queen of the early
2000s yes and where did that lead you
lead me business-wise or well I mean you
your career in the sex industry went
further than that it it went way further
than that I um spent a lot of time at
the Playboy Mansion going to parties and
meeting all kinds of um all kinds of
people
and uh met Heidi FES who's still a dear
friend of mine to this day and um really
changed my life I never went to clubs I
just you know if I wanted to go and meet
a boyfriend or have a date I'd meet them
at the Playboy Mansion that was that was
my life so I met a ton of celebrities
throughout the years
um
and met IDI
flies she kind of changed my life
forever in a good way um introduced me
to some wonderful men that um supported
me and gave me money and diamonds and
all those wonderful things tell me what
being one of Heidi F's girls was like
well you know I I met her after
everything had happened after she had
already served her time in jail oh
really and so she officially I wasn't
officially one of her girls but I was
her um her friend her best friend and
she did introduce me to several several
men throughout the years um
billionaires millionaires actors and uh
I did get paid
for hanging out with them I it was never
like a set price to where like when she
was actually involved in um pandering it
wasn't like that where i' would be paid
for the hour it was more of a hey have
this billionaire guy he wants to hang
out for the night will you do it and
then money would be involved at the end
but it was never like a per hour type of
situation or per minute it was just you
weren't on her roster huh you were not
on her I was not on that kind of roster
no she had already served her time and
she wasn't doing that anymore but she
still had several several friends and
acquaintances that wanted to hang out
with girls so and we had we had some
really good
times so you worked as an escort
basically yeah I would I would say God
gosh it's hard because it wasn't by the
hour I don't really know what that's
considered but yeah I would say so how
how long did that go on um oh years
years but most of the men that she
introduced me to became you know friends
as well that wasn't just um random
people Everyone that I saw I probably
saw them for
years
um yeah most of them became regulars I
guess you could say yeah what have you
learned about men from doing that kind
of
work they never
satisfied they're nothing um men with
that kind of money I
find it's just nothing's ever enough you
know um whether it's they want to add a
man to the situation or maybe a
transvestite or there was one guy in
particular who really um took it to
another level he there was he just
wanted to keep trying more things and I
would make make that happen happen for
him and um he just never seemed really
satisfied in the end um always wanted
more more Kink
more crazy more party more drugs more
more of everything and um after a while
that can get a little tiring sure you
know for drugs a part of your life yes
very much so from the age of nine
actually started early I started very
early my mom um used drugs and uh
because I didn't know how
to associate with her because she did
drugs and she loved the man and stuff I
decided instead of fighting her on it
that I would just instead of if you
can't beat him join them so I remember I
did my first line of cocaine with my
mother when I was 9 years old and
um that never stopped it
probably 20 30 years and she would say
that she couldn't even we couldn't even
be around the room in the same room
together without having to get high
first so that was the
relationship that we had and um but I
couldn't I couldn't be around her unless
I was on drugs I I just didn't
understand this woman and how could she
be my mother so but the drugs helped
that um and that was our relationship
drugs and
Men that's interesting
yeah and you've do you have children or
were you ever married I've I was married
twice just for um situational purposes
um both for green cards you know I met
guys when in my travels that wanted to
move to America um my first husband was
the local cocaine dealer in
Hollywood um so I married him he needed
his green card and then my second
husband pretty much the same situation
he just wanted to stay in America and
I'm like well why not it's easier to get
married than divorced I found so but
yeah um never had any children of my
own um animals were always my children
so I chose them over over human children
how would you look back at those
experiences of being an escort and
dating the higher level of client um
what was your I mean how did it affect
you emotionally I guess I never felt
that I was doing anything bad or wrong
it was two adults agreeing
on a transaction a transaction um you
know there were certain people that God
bless their souls they're not here
anymore that really took the party to
another level and did lose their lives
over it and um that's sad to hear about
you know years later that the party
never ended for them um for me it did I
had to I had to get out of it because I
didn't I didn't want to die and I didn't
want that to be my the end of me dying
of a drug overdose or dying of murder or
getting raped or any of that I didn't
want that and the people I was hanging
that I hung out with were at that level
of um it got scary even at that
level un
unbelievable situations and scenarios
and I just one day decided this is not
worth it I told my main um um client guy
that I no longer want to do this anymore
I can't do this your behavior and the
things that you're seeking and you
desire and that you're trying to get me
to be a part
of it's dangerous at this point you're
going to die and he ended up um a couple
years ago jumping from I think it was
like the 36th floor of his condominium
and killing himself really cuz the party
never stopped for for him but it wasn't
it was no longer a party it got to where
he you he was a
billionaire and then he
became just a
junkie um and I got thankfully I I had
the smarts because of growing up around
drugs kind of knowing when it was time
to just exit and to say it's not worth
the money it's not worth hanging out
with whomever it's just it was time time
to go and I think that saved my life in
many circumstances and many different
situations they always timing I just
always knew when it was just time to
time to go to leave the party yeah do
you look back at those times and have
pleasant memories of them or or I do
have pleasant memories but you know a
lot of sadness for the ones that didn't
um make it out that lifestyle eats
people up doesn't it it eats people up
and to lose your life over it and to
hurt people and use people and abuse
people just because you need to be
satisfied in a certain way it's it's
really kind of sick you know
um when is it ever enough yeah and when
is it when is the time to stop and who
will you not hurt to get what you want
you know it it's a very selfish
self-indulging lifestyle and I didn't
want that I had bigger dreams and
something I loved more than myself which
was animal yeah that reinforced
your love for Animals didn't it yes
absolutely do you do you see men
differently because of that experience I
do
um yeah obviously I'm single I still
single I'm I just turned 50 and um I
have you know a lot of trust issues I
know that especially in a city like Los
Angeles there's always the next best
thing and when you have that many
options most people think why not
you know like I know if I lived in
Minnesota if I would have stayed there I
would have been married after high
school and your life would looked very
my life would have been different but
when you have
options most people say why not and you
know nothing's really ever satisfying or
good enough for some
people no matter what the price you have
do you have regrets about getting into
it no I don't um
I no I you know I don't regret I never
I don't feel guilty I don't feel cuz I
never hurt anybody I never used anyone I
never
um did anything that didn't feel okay to
me you were just there for a good time I
was just there for a good time in the
money um when like I said when things
got bad and things got uncomfortable and
things got a little freakier than I
wanted to be then I would leave that was
it mhm I'm not going to stick around and
participate in some of the things that
were going on you know it's just not my
style what's the wildest thing you saw
um wow there there so many um just drugs
and and and sex and um hookers like
these men that I
knew woman was just not enough anymore
so after a while with the drugs they
wanted to
incorporate [__] for instance so i'
go on and try and you know find a [__]
that would come over to the house and
then it got to the point where we were
just cruising the streets trying to find
Street Walkers and getting drugs from
the street it wasn't where the drugs
were being delivered to our house
anymore we were just hanging out in a
mansion it got to you know points where
we're on the streets and we're in danger
and guns are being held to our heads and
you know that's when I think the the fun
ends and it becomes a
problem little too dangerous too
dangerous yes what what got you out of
that
um the last day that I saw my friend the
one that jumped out of the window of his
apartment building um I just I got I was
terrified the drugs had taken over he
went
from not doing drugs
to partaking sometimes then he went to
shooting up crystal meth then he went to
you know the streets and and this man
was had everything he was a billionaire
he he he had the best life and I I was
so terrified because no one wants to go
down alone you know they say misery
loves company and I would have went
probably with him and I didn't want that
I I I chose to live and walking away was
hard because these people did become my
friends and they were people I cared
about and but sometimes you just have to
choose yourself and love something
greater than yourself to get out of bad
situations and like I said for me it was
always the animals I wanted to open my
own own nonprofit I wanted to save the
animals of the world and and that's what
I did I I chose a greater cause than
myself and my partying ways and the
money I I
chose I chose what I love more than
myself where did you start I started a
501c3 nonprofit it was it it's the
animal rescue it was called a Lucky
Puppy and we would save dogs from the
city
shelters um and find forever home so I
created the first Humane pet store I
think probably in the world it was on
ventur Boulevard and we sold everything
that you would need to when you would
adopt a dog you know beds food um
whatever the dog might need and then we
would rescue the dogs from the shelter
take them to the vet at a Grooming Salon
upstairs they would get groomed and look
all fancy and they would just all be in
my store in the window and people would
walk by and come in and adopt dogs
from us that normally would have been
euthanized so in 3 years of having that
Humane pet store we
found homes for over, 1600 dogs that
would have been dead otherwise um and
because of the location I think and the
um just so it was fun it was like
Disneyland in there it was great we had
Girl Scouts volunteering and and it was
always my passion because animals like I
said were my best friends my whole life
um Tom Cruz adopted dogs for me um you
name it the the celebrity had been in my
store at Ellen degenerous um it was just
it was it was a dream it was like I said
it was like Disneyland for rescue dogs
it was it was probably the happiest
times of my life are you still doing are
you still doing it today no I lost um I
lost everything um
after my brother was murdered I had a uh
I have a brother I did have a brother
and uh when you rescue animals most
rescues don't think of like a Life Plan
like for instance what if you rescue a
dog and from the shelter you don't know
their behavior you don't know what
ailments they may have and I realized I
couldn't have every dog in a Humane pet
store what if they bit somebody or
whatever so I got a ranch in Santa
Clarita for the dogs that weren't really
adoptable at the time and we never would
be adoptable um I wanted a life plan for
them cuz once I adopted a dog or rescued
a dog they're mind for life I would
never return them to the shelter because
they were sick or whatever so I got a
ranch and that's where the dogs that
could be in the store would go to um I
hired a man
to kind of look over the ranch um I put
him on the lease he wasn't doing his uh
his duties he wasn't caring for the dogs
um just about 2 months later so I asked
my brother if he would move moved to my
Lucky Puppy Ranch and just kind of
oversee and make sure that he was doing
what he was supposed to do um 2 weeks
later that man um murdered my
brother and
uh after that the collateral damages as
you can imagine um were tremendous I
lost
everything um I lost my brother I lost
my animal rescue um I got sued by the
city of Los
Angeles um for animal abuse they charged
me with animal abuse I had to go to
trial for that
um just I lost everything so no I don't
have Lucky Puppy anymore but
um you it it was good while it lasted
and losing a brother especially in that
way has a lot of far-reaching effects
doesn't it it does it was um you know
the guilt of course that I felt for
asking him to help me and move up there
in the first place it was you know he
would have never been there if I hadn't
asked him to do it he would have done
anything for me um no questions asked
always um I didn't know that the man
that I had hired to look over the
animals was even capable of something
like that obviously um he was an act a
former actor he was
a a actor that played the Red Power
Ranger and the TV show for kids I guess
kids watch it everyone watches it um he
did a Power Rangers movie he played um
the Red Power Ranger in the movies and
um I didn't know any of this at the time
but um I quickly learned what you know
the night he killed my brother when TMZ
showed up at the ranch and I'm like oh
so he was an actor and he was his I
didn't I didn't know any of this this
was all kept a secret for me but
um he's he took a samurai sword and
stabbed my brother 10
times with the sword and killed him for
what reason I don't
know so did your brother do something to
instigate that no nothing that I know of
I just know that the man his name is
Ricardo Medina Jr he didn't want my
brother there and um we were planning on
kicking him out on February 1st we made
a plan with the landlord that we would
all we evicted cuz we didn't want him to
know that we didn't want him to get mad
say well why are they being why am I
being kicked out not them so he was
going to evict us all and then get rid
of Ricardo February 1st and then he
would resign the lease with me and my
brother and he murder my brother January
31st one day before he was going to be
evicted um in court they said that there
was an altercation that they got into a
fist
fight but the magnitude and the the
monst I don't even know how to describe
it the manner in which he took my
brother's life has destroyed my life um
he didn't shoot him he didn't beat him
up he didn't choke him
out to stab
someone it's very very personal and very
um just it was Overkill you he didn't he
didn't have to kill him in such a
horrible f passion and the guilt and the
everything that comes with it losing my
my dream my animals because of
collateral damage from what he had done
it's just I don't know how
to move
move I've moved on but I don't know if
I've moved forward um I'm kind of stuck
in grief maybe sure and guilt and uh
yeah what year was this 19 no sorry 2015
2015 so not that long ago not that long
ago so he's he's still in prison no he
was released um a couple years ago he
served um about 3 years three years for
murder for murder yes there was never a
trial he he pled out and um instead of
having to go through a murder trial he
made a deal with the um district
attorney that he would plead guilty to a
lesser charge and they sentenced him to
four
years for brutal murder so that was that
was
tough to cuz I spent he when he had
gotten arrested of course the night of
the murder and uh was released 3 days
later and the first three days I didn't
speak to the me every all the every TV
station every news they were following
me trying to get me to talk and I I
never said a word until I got a call
that he was being
released and my brain just went from
victim to monster I I just there was
nothing I wouldn't do to make sure that
this man paid the price for what he had
done to my brother so I spent a year
um doing everything in anything I had to
do to collect the evidence and to force
the people that should have
been doing their jobs to do their jobs
and um almost a year to the day after
his death he was finally re rearrested
because
of me solving my own brother's murder
basically um which no one should have to
solve their own brother's murder but I I
had no choice so and that's what I did
for a year and then they rearrested him
and charged
him this kind of put your life into a
tail spin it sounds like absolutely I
truly believed that um I know it sounds
silly to now I find it silly to say but
you know they say God only gives you
what you can
handle but that is just above and beyond
there's no I couldn't figure out you
know I'm the kind of person that won't
step on the Cracks I don't want anyone
in my family to get hurt you know I'm
very cautious and very loving and very
caring and I try not to do bad things to
people so I couldn't figure out why in
the world did this happen you know there
was no reason there was no and I I
didn't do anything to deserve it and I
could I handle it absolutely not um so
my go-to was I truly believe that God
hates me that was my thing that I would
say is God he just he [__] hates me
that's the only thing in my mind that
sounded correct at the time and you know
I put 100% of my time 100% of my effort
into fighting him
and befriending police officers and
screwing police officers and doing
whatever I had to do to get information
and to make them do the right thing um
and I did some dirty nasty things that
never thought I would do just to make
sure that Justice was served you had to
have sex with this police officer I
absolutely did yes to do what Just for
information
I wanted information I wanted to know
what was going on with the case because
you know everything's kept in you know
between themselves and I was the one
collecting evidence I was the one that
was talking to the media I was the one
that was getting the signs and figuring
out why the door wasn't really busted
down and and I just happened to run into
a sheriff at a
bar and he's like yeah of course I know
your case I'm Lieutenant so and so I'm
like okay well if you knows anything I'm
going to make sure he tells it to me and
so I took him home and uh got a little
information not not not enough that put
him in prison at the time but um I just
wanted to cause cause a Ruckus and make
let people know anyone and everyone now
that it shouldn't have gone down the way
it did and that my brother did not
deserve this nor was he the aggressor
and that this man needed to be in jail
and it worked do you feel like you were
the one who solved that case absolutely
absolutely yeah I do I they wouldn't
have done anything it was they were done
with it but it's got to be frustrating
that only 3 years was
served it hurts my soul and you know and
the day he was released I I made that
life decision
to to continue to go after him I was
going to be there with you know I was I
was even thinking May I'll hire a bunch
of motorcycle gang extras from sag and
just be outside of the jail and scare
the crap out of him when he gets out and
that was my focus was just making sure
that this man never forgets what he had
done and instead I I just laid in the
grass in my backyard and just just just
cried and cried and cried and cried and
that's the day I chose myself and I
chose to live and I can't keep fighting
this monster who has no soul and has no
regret what what is that going to do for
me continuously trying to ruin his life
even more than it already is um and you
have to believe at some point in karma
and everyone's like don't worry he'll
get his when he you know Karma will get
ham and you have to kind of just believe
that
otherwise what do you do you know so I
try to believe that Karma will take care
of him one day and I just chose to start
living my life again so then that's when
I knew that God really didn't hate me
that I was just saying that and um
that my brother is in a in a better
place and that he he was a kind person
and A Soulful person and extremely shy
person I'm shy but he's like he was
extremely shy and I just believe that he
was not meant to be here but I'm haunted
you know I have severe
PTSD I have um night terrors I don't
even have to go to bed thinking about
what had happened to my brother it just
happen comes in my dreams so that's you
know something that I'm trying to learn
to cope with um I have sleep paralysis
and that just comes whenever it feels
like it um so the manner in which he
took his life is haunts me even when I'm
not thinking about it CU it was so
gruesome and unnecessary he cut all my
brother's fingertips off cuz my brother
was trying to stop him from stabbing him
with a with a samurai sword 3ot samurai
sword so that's hard to and I you know
all I've ever wanted to do is take care
of animals
and love people and it turns into this
and it turns into this and it's
um I don't I can't I don't know the
reason and I felt like I was definitely
like an alien on this planet like I
didn't wrong here I tried to join
support groups and actually felt like
jealousy over other people whose child
had been shot and I'm like what the [__]
is wrong with me why am I jealous
because I found in my mind I think
that's more
humane way to to die than the way my
brother was killed you know he was
chopped up he was disolved he
was it was just you don't ever hear of
anyone killing someone like that you
know so for a long time I felt so alone
on this planet thinking that oh I wish
my brother would have just been shot you
know I had that attitude and then one
day I just thought you know what pain is
pain and loss is loss and it all feels
the same no matter
how it whatever the situation is it
still feels the same for
everybody I think and I hope so I don't
think my pain is any less painful than
someone that's lost
their dog
or um stub their toe it's still painful
and that's what I try and tell myself
that it's it's all the same we're all
human and we
feel those things and that's helped me
get by because thinking of that my
situation is so much different than
someone being shot or stubbing their toe
makes me alienate myself from the world
and I did that for so many
years and I I don't want to do that
anymore have you had any close human
friends in your
life um I've had a couple I have my besy
Sandra um she was my brother's
girlfriend so I'm kind of stuck to her
like glue because you know we've been
through it together but um animals are
your thing animals are my thing you know
I trust everybody the same that's that's
my problem I I I would give a homeless
person or a billionaire the same
attention and the same
chance and I don't have that filter
where I think that people can be
bad and I learned the hard way that
people can be very
horrible and uh it's just I still it
doesn't resonate in my an empath I don't
understand
how that's even a thing how can you how
can you hate and how can you be cruel
and it just it's not in my chemical
makeup to have that kind of feeling but
that man that killed my brother taught
me how to feel hate for the first time
and taught me like people are like you
just need to
forgive him and just let it go and
uh I will
not you know he's not a human to me I
can I will forgive a human being but to
me he's a
monster and always will be and that's
why I think my feelings of hate are
warranted for
him Rachel what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
all of this in all this in your your
colorful life colorful life always just
stay true to who you are and don't let
outside factors or people's opinions or
what they do change who you
are change who you are I've been through
hell and back and been with the richest
and the the poorest and the everything
but I'm still that same little girl that
loves guinea pigs end of the day
yeah you know and that'll never change
and all the bad stuff has not changed to
I am nor will ever let
it maybe it's naive I don't know
but but I'm still the same person that's
great all right Rachel thank you so much
for sharing your story oh thank you I
hope hope things get better for you from
here thank you thank
you